et sur le front diplomatique la france
elle continue de garder contact avec la
russie manuel mâcon c'est ainsi une
nouvelle fois entretenu avec vladimir
poutine ceux des manches 1h45
d'entretien par téléphone selon l'elysée
alors que retenir de cet entretien on va
voir tout ça avec notre chroniqueur
international bruno daroux rebonjour
bruno bruno que retenir de ce nouvel
échange téléphonique entre vladimir
poutine et emmanuel macron donc oui
c'est le quatrième appel téléphonique
entre les deux présidents preuve que
pour la lumière poutine il est important
quand même de maintenir le contact pour
vladimir mac ou pour vladimir pour
emmanuel macron pardon c'est la même
chose alors cette fois ci d'ailleurs
l'elysée précise que l'appel s'est fait
l'initiative d' emmanuel macron la fois
précédente c'était à l'initiative de
vladimir poutine donc 1h45 de discussion
où il y a une petite avance et on va
dire concernant la sécurité des
centrales nucléaires civiles évidemment
après l'épisode de zaporijia et puis
auparavant la prise de tchernobyl par
les russes donc apparemment vladimir
poutine s'est dit ouvert à une
concertation avec les occidentaux et
avec les ukrainiens aussi pour éviter
que ces centrales soient prises pour
cible parce qu'il faut savoir qu'il y à
un certain nombre de centrales
nucléaires civiles en ukraine même si du
coup la prise de zaporijia parler parler
russe est donc actée en quelque sorte
mais en tout cas là dessus il ya une
forme d'ouverture alors que demain
d'ailleurs il ya une réunion assez
attendu de laguiole agence
internationale pour l'énergie atomique
donc ça c'est la petite avancée du jour
mais qui est toujours bon à prendre sur
les corridors humanitaires là c'était un
peu plus le dialogue de sourds puisque
emmanuel macron a insisté pour que ces
corridors humanitaires soient donc en
place et permettent réellement
l'évacuation de civils vladimir poutine
lui continue de rejeter la faute sur les
ukrainiens il dit que son armée ne
prenait pas pour cible des bâtiments
civils ou des personnes civiles un peu
contre l'évidence on a envie de dire et
puis enfin désaccord persistant sur le
sur le fond du problème c'est à dire que
la russie continue à présenter ses
exigences à l'ukraine mais aussi à
l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale c'est à dire la
démilitarisation du pays là
dénazification du régime
l'indépendance garantie de la crimée et
du donbass ça fait beaucoup c'est trop
ce n'est pas acceptable et donc de ce
point de vue là pas d'avancées mais
quand même on continue à se parler et
pour emmanuel macron outre l'aspect
intérieur sur lequel je n'insiste pas
trop il est il est désormais aussi
président candidat évidemment pour lui
cette stature de partenaire privilégié
quand même avec vladimir poutine il
n'est pas le seul mais c'est avec lui
que vladimir poutine s'entretient le
plus souvent évidemment pour sa posture
internationale et à quelques semaines de
l'élection présidentielle
c'est bon à prendre mais sinon les
choses n'avancent pas néanmoins le
secrétaire américain le secrétaire
d'état américain anthony blinken va
s'arrêter à paris mardi pour
s'entretenir avec emmanuel macron parce
que les américains eux ne parlent plus
directement avec vladimir poutine à
emmanuel macron qu'est ce ce espèce de
rôle de croix transmission d'une
certaine d'une certaine manière bruno
est un mot avec vous sur la position de
la démarche lean et vous l'avez évoqué
mais il a dit vladimir poutine lors de
cet entretien ce qu'il en est ressorti
il dit j'obtiendrai ce que je veux que
ce soit par la force par la guerre ou
sur le front diplomatique là encore une
fois c'est un peu ça de toute façon il
présente ses exigences voilà ce que je
vous disais à dénazification
démilitarisation
indépendance de la crimée indépendance
du dombass donc il ya en gros c'est à
prendre ou à laisser mais absent
vladimir poutine il est un peu comme ça
depuis depuis le début finalement il dit
voilà voilà les exigences donc soit on
règle ça de manière courtoise par la
diplomatie soir que sa part la guerre
circulez ya rien à voir voilà comment il
conçoit la négociation donc c'est quand
même ça qui rend les choses quand même
extrêmement compliqué merci beaucoup
bruno daroux pour cet éclairage vonona
ou chroniqueurs internationale pour un
france 24